Hong Kong is a bastion of free
expression art culture and commerce
while mainland China was being ravaged
by Mao's Cultural Revolution in the
1960s Hong Kong was still a British
colony and home to a radical experiment
in free-market capitalism it's thriving
bustling dynamic city has been made
possible by the free market indeed the
freest market in the world
Britain returned Hong Kong to China
today indeed 156 years of colonial rule
by the time partial control was handed
over to the Chinese government creating
the one country two systems' model per
capita wealth here had eclipsed that of
even the UK that experiment may be
coming to an abrupt end China's People's
Congress adopted a national security law
that would allow the mainland to clamp
down on civil liberties destroying the
political freedom that made this
semi-autonomous city a desirable place
to live the US government has threatened
to revoke Hong Kong's special trading
partner status and levy targeted
sanctions to oppose Beijing's actions
but there's another foreign policy lever
the government could pull that's
nonviolent humane and beneficial to u.s.
citizens make it easier for Hong Kongers
to leave by welcoming them into America
not only would it be good for them but
it would also be good for the West
Ilia soman is a law professor at George
Mason University and the author of the
new book free to move foot voting
migration and political freedom he
argues that the US should have an
open-door policy to Hong Kongers and
eventually mainland Chinese dissidents
as well the United Kingdom has already
announced plans to extend visas for up
to three million fleeing Hong Kongers
they would make important contributions
to our economies just as previous
Chinese and Hong Kong immigrants and
others from that part of the world have
done
second this would be a very important
victory in the war of ideas that is
arising between the US and the West in
the one hand and the authoritarian
government of China on the other those
who could benefit most from such an
escape hatch are critics of the Chinese
Communist Party like Joshua Wong who has
already had a taste of what it's like to
lose your civil liberties he was
arrested in his home in 2019 in an
effort by
Hong Kong officials to undermine the
large protest plan for the following day
and he was barred from running for
office because of his political party's
stated belief that Hong Kongers should
be allowed to determine the city
sovereignty by democratic vote I was
some of this national security law as a
speech crime once you call on President
Xi Jinping to step down you might be
arrested prosecuted I may not be
arrested by Hong Kong police but
arrested by Beijing appointed agent of
secret police the prosecution might not
take place in Hong Kong
it might take place in mainland China I
might be a lot of in prison in Beijing
that's a nightmare what if before that
happens Wong and other Hong Kong
activists had the option to get out
Democrats they want open borders and
they don't mind crime think of it even
the immigration box within the Trump
administration soman argues should
appreciate that granting automatic entry
to Hong Kongers would be a politically
savvy move against the Chinese regime
horrified by the difficulties faced by
displaced Jews during and after World
War two President Truman piloted
America's first refugee program starting
with a 1945 executive order followed by
the displaced persons Act of 1948
America granted similar status to
refugees of communist Cuba in 1966 and
the Soviet Union starting in 1953
including summons parents who left in
1979 when he was 5 years old the US
government at the time recognized of
course that hard reason to do this place
can help repress people for its own sake
but they also recognized that it was an
important moral victory for the US and
the cold war struggle against the Soviet
Union soman Jewish family was considered
a persecuted ethnic minority but he
believes all Hongkongers faced with the
loss of their freedoms should be given
the opportunity to exit another
Hongkonger at risk is Sixtus Baggio
Leung who voters elected in 2016 to the
Legislative Council but lost his
position after showing up at a
swearing-in ceremony draped in a banner
that read Hong Kong is not a part of
China in 2018 the government sentenced
Leung to four weeks in prison after can
acting him of illegally trying to
re-enter the legislature to retake his
oaths China's new law unambiguously
criminalizes Long's pro-independence
views which he explained to reason in
2019 if Hong Kong remained under the
ruling of CCP we can never achieving
like universal suffrage like separation
of power like freedom of speech like all
kind of freedom once China implements
the new law all of Hong Kong citizens
will likely find their speech movements
and other liberties increasingly
curtailed the National Security Law will
just control the free flow of
information and a free flow of capital
soman wants the u.s. to go farther than
the UK by extending to Hong Kongers and
eventually all Chinese dissidents and
offer of permanent residency to get into
the u.s. people wait for years including
other refugees such as Syrians who were
just blocked from getting in here would
it be fair to let Hong Kongers and
eventually Chinese dissidents jump the
line in that sense the way to remedy
that kind of injustice is not to keep
out Chinese or specific sub categories
like Hong Kongers is to address the
issue by making it easier to let in more
people in the future there really is no
line right now Trump has virtually shut
down letting in virtually any refugees
of any kind the Trump administration has
been dismantling the refugee system
first by capping the number of people
allowed in from Syria and other Middle
Eastern countries and then with his
remain in Mexico policy which forces
those applying for refugee status to
wait outside the country political
reports that a component of the gops
2020 election strategy is to make an
aggressive stance towards China a
central issue and portray their
opponents as soft on China
Solman says this presents an opportunity
if they're real china hawks and they
should welcome this opportunity to both
get some of China's most talented people
to come here as opposed to stay in China
where they will be under the control of
that government and at the same time
when an important moral and political a
treant Wang however has no immediate
plans to leave Hong Kong
he says he's hanging around
to resist the Communist Party's takeover
of his city for as long as he can
I've no hope to as the government
archives due to his Kibo and a global
community we can keep our momentum and
that Beijing to realize that how we
never stopped our fight
[Music]
you